-We love you.
Michael Strahan.
-Hey. I got you.
I love you guys.
Thank you so much for that.
-Yeah.
-And always got to shout-out
my guys, The Roots.
Thank you guys, man, for playing
that "Fly Like the Eagles."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You like that, right?
-They think they're slick.
-Yeah.
-Football season's not here yet.
You're always strutting
with the Eagles stuff.
It's all good. I'll be back
when we're stomping you guys.
But it's okay.
[ Laughter ]
-You know, this is the --
Do you know that this is
the 17th time you've --
you appeared on our show.
-I can't believe it.
-And it's a record for us.
Most appearance
by any guest ever is you,
Michael Strahan, on our show.
-Really?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Really?
Wow!
-And I'm so happy
that you've come back.
And thank you.
-Thank you, man.
-You're a great guest.
-Well, I love being here, man.
I love being here.
It's like family.
You guys are great.
You have the best audience
in television.
So, thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Even though The Roots
give you a hard time.
You know we love you.
-Yeah, I love it, though.
-Roots give you a hard time.
They got it.
They're Philly.
I always have so many things
to talk to you about.
And this one, I cannot wait
'Cause this -- we haven't
talked about this.
And we're friends,
but we've not talked about this.
-Mm-hmm.
-You went to space.
-I did.
I went to space!
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-You did the Jeff Bezos --
you did the Blue Origin rocket.
-Yeah, man.
-Look at this.
That's you.
-That's me.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Now was that before
you took off?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Or is this when you landed?
-That was, um --
That's actually
when we're going up.
-Really?
-Yeah.
And it's, like,
it's pushing my face back.
[ Laughter ]
So, you start with a smile,
and it gets bigger.
Only thing it didn't do was
push my teeth together, but...
[ Laughter ]
It was --
It was incredible.
It was absolutely --
-Now, talk to me.
Please tell me.
What -- What -- What --
-It was the most incredible
thing I've ever done.
-You're wearing the outfit.
You're strapped in,
you go, "Here you go,"
you take off,
and then you're like --
Do you wait for a ding?
Like a, "boong!" -- "You can
take your seat belt off now"?
-No. You're sitting there,
and you hear the countdown.
And they're counting down,
and you're thinking,
"Okay, it's too late.
Can't get off.
I'm in it.
Let's just do it."
-Oh, my God.
-And then, it takes off,
and it starts rumbling,
and the cabin turns red
from all the flames from below.
-Oh, my God.
-And then it was like --
It feels like you're in a movie.
Like, I feel like I'm, like,
in "Apollo 13" movie.
Like, thing is shaking,
and it says,
"You've cleared the tower,"
and literally every one of us,
all six of us, just let out
the biggest happy yell.
Because it was like
all this pressure and relief.
And then, once you get
to a certain point,
you realize you're going over
2,000 miles per hour,
and you're hitting
all these G's,
and next thing you know,
you're at 40,000 feet.
You're like, "Oh, I've been
in a plane that high."
Then you look, and you're
200,000 or 300,000 feet.
And then they release
the capsule from the rocket,
and you're body goes...
And then the light goes off.
And it goes "Ding!
You are free to roam the cabin."
-No!
[ Laughter and applause ]
I was waiting for it!
Like, yeah!
Tie me up and go --
[ Both laugh ]
You got me!
You got me.
-The light does goes off,
and then you undo your belt.
It was surreal.
And you should come with me
next time, man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Me and you!
Let's go!
-I'm busy that --
I'm busy that weekend.
-I'll give you a date.
I'm busy that week--
[ Laughter ]
Would you ever go --
would you go back?
-You know what?
When I got off the rocket,
Jeff Bezos said, "Next time,
we'll go to the Moon."
-Oh, my God.
-And I was so fired up,
I'm like, "Yeah!"
[ Laughter ]
And now I think about it,
I'm like, "I don't know!"
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah.
You're always a very,
very busy man.
You have your own menswear line,
very successful.
You have your own skin care line
coming out this fall.
-Yeah, man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What is that called?
-It's called skin care.
[ Laughter ]
-Is that the name of it?
-Yeah.
It's called skin care,
Michael Strahan.
-It's called skin care?
-Yeah.
Michael Strahan.
-There you go.
You just laid it out.
-Same thing.
-Wow.
-But it's coming out
in the fall.
-All right.
So in the fall we'll talk.
Will you come back for that?
-You know,
I can't throw it out there now.
They told me,
"Don't say too much about it now
'cause it's not out yet."
So I can't say anything.
-Let's not
say anything about it.
-Yes. I got to come back in
for the 18th time.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
18's the lucky number.
-18's the lucky number.
-And then you
have this production company
with Tom Brady.
-Yeah.
-Religion of Sports.
-Yes.
-It just won another
sports Emmy, by the way.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-You keep winning these awards.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well done.
Did you guys talk about
when he was about to retire?
-Oh, absolutely.
Yeah, I played golf with him.
And we're playing golf,
and I'm telling him, I'm like,
"Dude, let me tell you,
when you're done,
you will never
strap a helmet on,
you will never put on another
pair of shoulder pads.
It's done.
Like, you just won't do it
ever again."
And I knew
he wasn't gonna retire.
I knew he wasn't.
He wasn't done.
You know, Tom,
he's turning 45 tomorrow.
Happy birthday, Tom Brady.
-Yeah, happy birthday Tom Brady.
-Turning 45 tomorrow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I don't know
how he keeps on going.
But I can tell
he still wants to get
every bit of football
out of him.
And at that point,
after that conversation,
I realized
he wasn't gonna retire.
-Yeah.
-So I wasted a whole tweet,
Instagram post.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, congratulations, Tom Brady!
Great career!"
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
You sent a really nice tweet.
Will you send it again?
-I'm just gonna
retweet the same thing.
[ Laughter ]
Why?
I'm not wasting my time.
He got it out of me once.
That's good enough.
-Just gonna cut and paste?
-Yeah, cut and paste, man.
-Just cut and paste.
Why not?
Let's talk about
"$100,000 Pyramid."
-Oh, man.
-Oh, man, this is a fun show.
I got a taste of, you know,
hosting a game show.
And it's fun.
-It is.
-And you get to have all these
cool celebrities on.
-Yeah.
-I know Jason Alexander's
come on, Wiz Khalifa was on.
Do you find certain professions
are better
than other professions?
-Yes. Yes.
[ Laughter ]
Certain people are just better,
but definitely the professions
kind of --
comedians are really good.
-Yeah.
-Musicians and comedians
are good, because their careers
are like wordplay.
You got to think about it.
A musician is like playing with
words to make you feel emotion,
and so you have to know
pretty much the dictionary.
You know that.
-Yeah.
-And Wiz Khalifa was insane!
The comedians,
they're taking words
to make you laugh
and make you feel
some kind of emotion.
And I was surprised
because I'm like,
"Oh, a comedian -- anybody
can make anybody laugh."
That's just not true.
"Musicians, you're just talented
at making music."
It's just not true.
They are so good at word play.
-Yeah.
-And then a lot of people
you think are really smart,
which they are, they're just --
they're dumb at this game.
[ Laughter ]
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's a peek at this season
of "The $100,000 Pyramid."
Take a look at this.
-Oh, gosh, like,
"I'm just so drunk."
-Lush.
-Yep.
And then,
another word for your butt.
Your --
-Tush.
-Yep.
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was awesome.
-In the intro, I said,
"You're good with words."
She didn't even say anything,
you said, "Lush."
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I'm like,
"Hottie -- very lush."
Okay.
-Also, she's very drunk, so...
-I'm wasted.
[ Laughter ]
-You got to have a good face.
You got to have a go--
-You got to have...
But the faces are natural,
because like I said,
I don't know the words,
so I'm guessing along
with everybody else, man.
But it's so much fun.
And hopefully
everybody enjoys it.
-We love you.
Michael Strahan, everybody.
"The $100,000 Pyramid"
airs Sunday nights at 9:00 p.m.
on ABC!
Michael and I are doing
something fun after the break,
so stick around.
Come on back.
Don't change that channel.
Come on.